The
guy who
messed up your math routine with your well-mannered furniture told you that you're a child actor and that you shouldn't have a wallet, and
the boiling point of laughter plummets.
It's good, but I
'm afraid I'll be banned Respectful witch chair melody
oil
[music]
What's wrong with that subtle reaction
?
It's the first time I've had an art photo taken at the studio I was in.
Well then, it's probably the previous band
members.  I got it from someone in the photography department at a place
[music] Turn it
off I
know one thing, but now
it's embarrassing, huh?
Childhood is difficult, so
I'm afraid I'll be in trouble if
I don't include an amateur band
.
Don't corner me with raw main words
, please tell me it's a case for Mr. Haruki.
In the
first place, I can't understand the thoughts of people born in the 1st war era
.